the EU General Affairs Council has  marked the 10th anniversary of the  European Union's Big Bang enlargement  into Eastern Europe the enlargement on  may first 2004 with teus biggest ever  taking in eight Central and Eastern  European countries as well as Cyprus and  Malta it's now clear to everyone that  the transition from 15 to 25 to 27 and  recently to 28 has turned out remarkably  well that the large month has proven  again and again to be a success story  for the European family The ministers  also prepared for the summit of EU  leaders in June which will mark the end  of the Greek presidency the summit's to  focus on immigration economic growth and  jobs and climate change and energy